to the question for you so in fact for
everyone for everyone so so if uh if the
if a Bim man said you know lies and says
I'm a doctor you know or Michael Jordan
himself or whatever yeah
um and he's Prime yeah and a girl sleeps
with him because of that
and it found finds out she was lied to
is that is that is this is there
something a bit
can I get to the question though can I
get to the actual question yeah I've
presented it but let me let me ask the
question is there
any kind of responsibility or is there
is there anything weird about the girl
choosing to sleep with someone because
of this state is or title or whatever is
there any wrong there wow
I'm asking I'm asking a question we've
just presented that women are not good
bosses women are not good leaders
therefore men have to do it so if you
don't have the leadership skills for
most women
CEO and you are a bin man yeah but you
have to lie and say a not a bit because
you're not proud I would I mean I could
be with a bin man if you say it with
chess
I don't think I don't think my question
is being understood so but gone Karen do
you understand what you're saying you're
saying that why if a woman has sex with
a man because of his title yeah isn't
that a form of manipulation but why did
the man lie about his title because he
knew about that woman not me but that
woman care more about the title than the
person cool let's get to that let's
let's definitely the right one wait hold
on hold on hold on let's definitely get
to the man lying because that's wrong
okay cool but what about the what about
step one of the woman sleeping with the
man because like okay let's let's take
let's I have an example let's take the
tender swim there it wasn't just one
woman yeah that was many like he was
doing that everywhere but he was picking
a specific sorry to cut you if I was but
I feel like he was picking a specific
type of women woman sorry so like women
that were not you know he knew they had
money he'd done his research he's not
gonna go talk to their Brokenness woman
but he was making sure that they was you
know single he'll make sure that they
was kind of you know you know in a
country that had good credit yeah you
know that you know I mean he was picking
wisely so he targeted he was targeting
women that he knew were vulnerable and
that's like that's a different type of
you know manipulation in a sense but
what we're saying is like if a guy's got
a job and you're happy with your job and
you want a certain type of girl I feel
like you should present yourself as that
person just be real to yourself I agree
with you but his point is is it's a
question is there anything wrong with
women sleeping with the man just for his
titles no no there's nothing wrong with
it so the man so the man lying is the
only wrong in that situation okay sorry
my point was so so wait wait let me let
me just clarify it there's two steps
here there's two there's two things here
let me I'm gonna give it to her she
hasn't finished
I'm gonna let her lunch so Step One is
the man the man lied about his um status
yeah yeah step two is the woman slept
with him because of his status are are
they both wrong or is it is it only the
man that's wrong I think he's wrong for
lying because I think everyone should be
their authentic self we only get one
life two a woman should be allowed to
sleep with whoever she feels like has a
certain status because men do the same
like they don't sleep with them if a
woman's at home
but I'm saying I'm saying women men
don't sleep with women for status they
sleep with they sleep with women for
beauty and arguably women
um choose more for beauty than men do um
they're much more picky on dead their
weight but they're wait they're much
more picky on dating apps and like even
when they when they study like women on
a chart like women rate 80 of women is
unattractive or sorry I have men sorry
so the equivalent the equivalent for a
man would be is it wrong for a man not
to sleep with a woman who's not
beautiful or a woman who hasn't had
makeup or woman has and had surgery I'm
saying to you men look for different
things women look for different things I
think everyone should just go for
whatever that's something
can we can we really say to men be
Arthur okay wait can we can we really
say to man be authentic when again women
women the Instagram filters the botox
the lip filler the the chin implants the
Chicken Plants all the modifications
that women tend to do or have done and I
feel like they're very visible and men
are aware of them that's the whole
difference yeah but guys use steroids
there's a way there's an awareness I
feel like there's an awareness when it
comes to women because we're very like
fooled with certain things men have a
bit more strategy when it comes towards
how they would like to find a woman or
to get what they would lack from a woman
so that comes down to them telling them
this job or accidentally drive this car
or they dress fancy for a specific type
of I've seen guys
which do you think is more common I men
lion
if you guys want to do this we can do
this but what before we can do this
it's not even War but I would need
everyone to take off the makeup I will
need everyone to take out any hair which
is not their natural hair anything on
your nails which is not yours will need
to do that if you've got Botox in there
we have to squeeze it all out yeah I
mean no no no so don't
forget basically but basically and then
what's wrong not what's wrong with lip
filler hold on hold on a second if
you're gonna say that's a lie then
everything you girls are doing is
ablated line we can see the light but
yet we allow it because you know what I
mean this is what I'm trying to say so
wait hold on hold on a second um so the
better question would be the reverse of
it if a woman lies about her body count
yeah is that not manipulation and then
if I find out you've lied about your
body count to me it is equal to you a
man lying about his status or my about
his job because for men for men body
count is way more important so I know a
man that got me yes I know a man yes it
is it is it's very important and the men
that say it's not important is because
they don't hang around to be a husband
they just run up your body count and
give it to the next guy so anyone's
wondering so I can no no I'm saying so
any guy that says body count is not
important because he doesn't have good
intentions for you why would he say it's
important when he's about to go to a
next girl do you understand but I
promise you this the woman he settles
with he's gonna find it very important
so if we're going to say that it's a
manipulation tactic for men to talk
about are to to you know if he's a bin
bin guy and he says a footballer but you
still sleep with him like he said why
are you sleeping on someone like that
but if we're gonna do it the opposite
way round then if women lie you need to
It's like white thing at home yeah so
basically if you lie about your body
count if you lie about your body count
then I find out I don't care if it's
five years six years we can have a kid
you're going do you know why you're
going because my relationship was built
upon a lie the same way you slept with a
guy that was built upon a lie before you
can say to men what you're saying make
sure you're not lying about anything and
a lot and right now lies Eliza light and
right now a lot of you girls are lying
on here
who does who does which more do women
lie about their body counts more often
than men lie about their jobs
I'm talking about personally as a whole
like generalization like as men
sometimes they do have like you know
like you would say like paint that
Goodwill as many of you know I was just
banned on Tick Tock and we and we're
demonetized on a daily basis
term if you want to help please consider
sending a super thanks below every
donation helps and it helps make what we
do possible